for people curious to kind of learn more
so this is more like
it's not middle school we're going to go
to elementary school for a second
maybe middle let's go to middle school
so
if i were to try to maybe write a
write a pamphlet of like
wolfram physics project for dummies
aka for me or maybe make a video on the
basics
but not just the basics of the physics
project but
the basics plus the most beautiful
central ideas how would you go
about doing that could you help me out a
little bit yeah yeah i mean
you know really practical matter we have
this kind of visual summary
picture that we made that's right um
which i think is a pretty good
you know when i've tried to explain this
to people and
you know it's a pretty good place to
start is you've got this rule
you know you apply the rule you're
building up this this big hypograph
um you've got all these possibilities
you're kind of thinking about that in
terms of quantum mechanics
i mean that's a that's a that's a decent
place to start so basically
the things we've talked about which is
space represented as a hypograph
transformation of that space is kind of
time
yes and then uh structure of that space
uh the curvature of that space says
gravity
that can be explained without going
anywhere near quantum mechanics
um i would say that's actually easier to
explain than special relativity
um oh so going into general so going to
curvature
yeah i mean special relativity i i think
is it's a little bit elaborate to
explain
yeah and honestly you only care about it
if you know about special relativity if
you know how specialism it is ordinarily
derived and so on
and i think relativity is easier it's
easier yes and then what about
what's the easiest way to reveal i think
the the basic point is just
this fact that there are all these
different branches that there's this
kind of map of how the branches work
and that um i mean i think
i think actually the recent things that
we have about the double experiment
are pretty good
because you can actually see this you
can see how the double slit
you know phenomenon arises from just
features of these graphs
now you know having said that right
there is a little bit of
of slight of hand there because the
the true story of the way that double
slit thing works
depends on the coordination of branchial
space
that for example in our internal team
there is still a
vigorous battle going on about how that
works and it's it's what's becoming
clear
is i mean what's becoming clear is that
it's mathematically really quite
interesting
i mean that is that there's a you know
it involves essentially putting
space-filling curves you'll basically
have a thing which is naturally
two-dimensional
and you're sort of mapping it into one
dimension and with a space-filling curve
and it's like why is it this place
feeling covered on another space-filling
curve
and that becomes a story about riemann
surfaces and things
and it's quite elaborate and um but but
the
there's a moral little bit slight of
hand way of doing it
where it's you know it's surprisingly
direct it's
so a question that might be difficult to
answer
but uh for several levels of people
could you give me advice
on how we can learn more specifically
there is people that are completely
outside and just curious
and are captivated by the beauty of
hypergraphs
actually so people there just want to
explore play around with this
uh second level is people from
say people like me who somehow got a phd
in computer science but are not
physicists
and but fundamentally the work you're
doing is a computational nature
so it feels very accessible yes so
what are what can a person like that do
to learn
enough physics or not to be able to
uh one explore the beauty of it and two
that's the final level of contribute
something
right of a level of even publishable
right like strong interesting ideas
right at all those layers complete
beginner yeah right ics person and the
cs person that wants to publish right i
mean i think that
you know i've written a bunch of stuff
uh person called jonathan gorod who's
been a key person working on this
project he's also written a bunch of
stuff
um and some other people started writing
things too and he's a physicist
physicist well he's i would say a
mathematical physicist
he's pretty mathematically sophisticated
he's he regularly out mathematicizes me
yeah this strong yeah strong
mathematical thesis yeah
i looked at some of the papers right but
but so so i mean
you know i wrote this kind of original
announcement
blog post about this project which
people seem to have found
uh i've been really happy actually that
people um
who uh you know people seem to have
grocked
key points from that much deeper key
points
people seem to have grocked than i
thought they would grock
and then that's a kind of a long blog
post that explains some of the things we
talked about like the hyper graph and
the basic rules
yes and uh i don't does it i forget that
it doesn't have any quantum mechanics
yeah it goes through quantum mechanics
yes it does but we we know a little bit
more since that blog post
that probably clarifies but that blog
post is does a pretty decent job
um and you know talking about things
like again some of you didn't mention
the fact that the uncertainty principle
is a consequence of curvature in
brownshield space how much physics
should a person know to be able to
understand
the beauty of this framework and to
contribute something novel okay so i
think that
those are different questions so i mean
i think that
the why does this work why does this
make any sense
um uh to really know that you have to
know a fair amount of physics
okay um and for example when you say
why does this work you're referring to
the connection between this model
and general relativity for example you
have to understand something about
general lots of data there's not so
there's also a side of this where just
as the pure mathematical framework is
fascinating
yes if you throw the physics out right
then it's quite accessible to
i mean you know i i wrote this sort of
long technical introduction to the
project
which seems to have been very accessible
to people who are
you know who understand computation and
formal abstract ideas
but are not specialists in physics or
other kinds of things
i mean the thing with the physics part
of it is
you know it's there's both a way of
thinking
and a literally a mathematical formalism
i mean it's like
you know to know that we get the
einstein equations to know we get the
initial momentum tensor
you kind of have to know what the energy
momentum tensor is and that's
physics i mean that's kind of graduate
level physics basically
um and uh so so that you know making
that final connection
is requires some depth of physics
knowledge
i mean that's the unfortunate thing the
difference in machine learning and
physics in the 21st century
is it uh really out of reach of a year
or two worth of study no you could get
it in a year or two
but you can't get it in a month right i
mean so but it doesn't require
necessarily like 15 years no it does not
and in fact a lot of what
has happened with this project makes a
lot of this stuff much more accessible
there are things where it has been quite
difficult to explain what's going on and
it requires
much more you know having the
concreteness of being able to do
simulations
knowing knowing that this thing that you
might have thought was just an analogy
is really actually what's going on makes
one
feel much more secure about just sort of
saying this is how this works
um and i think it will be you know the
i'm hoping the textbooks of the future
the physics textbooks of the future
there will be a certain compression
there will be things that used to be
very much more elaborate because
for example even doing continuous
mathematics versus this discrete
mathematics
that you know to know how things work in
continuous mathematics you have to be
talking about stuff and waving your
hands about
things whereas with discrete the
discrete version it's just like
here is a picture this is how it works
and there's no
oh do we get the limit right did this
you know did this thing that is of
you know zero you know measure zero
object you know interact with this thing
in the right way
you don't have to have that whole
discussion it's just like here's a
picture
you know this is what it does and you
know you can
then it takes more effort to say what
does it do in the limit when the picture
gets very big but you can do experiments
to build up an intuition actually yes
right and
you can get sort of core intuition for
what's going on now in terms of
contributing to this
the you know i would say that the study
of the computational universe and how
all these programs work in the
computational universe
there's just an unbelievable amount to
do there and
it is very close to the surface that is
you know
high school kids you can do experiments
it's not um you know and you can
discover things i mean you know
we you can discover stuff about i don't
know like this thing about expansion of
branchial space that's an absolutely
accessible thing to look at
now you know the main issue with doing
these things is not
there isn't a lot of technical depth
difficulty there the actual doing of the
experiments you know
all the code is all on our website to do
all these things
the real thing is sort of the judgment
of what's the right experiment to do how
do you interpret what you see
that's the part that you know people
will do amazing things with
and that's the part that but but it
isn't like you have to have done
10 years of of study to get to the point
where you can do the experiments you
just did
a cool thing you can do experiments day
one basically right that's that
that that's the amazing thing about and
you've actually put the tools out there
yeah it's beautiful it's mysterious uh
there's
still i would say maybe you can correct
me it feels like there's a huge number
of log-hanging
fruit on the mathematical side at least
not uh
not the physics side perhaps no there's
look on the on the
okay on the physics side we are we're
definitely in harvesting mode
you know of which which fruit the
low-hanging ones are
the low-hanging all right yeah right i
mean basically here's the thing
there's a certain list of you know here
are the effects in quantum mechanics
here are the effects in general activity
it's just like industrial harvesting
it's like
can we get this one this one this one
this one this one and the thing that's
really
you know interesting and satisfying and
it's like you know is one climbing the
right mountain doesn't have the right
model
the thing that's just amazing is you
know we keep on like
are we gonna get this one how hard is
this one
it's like oh you know it looks really
hard it looks really hard
oh actually we can get it um and
uh and you're you're continually
surprised i mean it seems like i've been
following your progress
it's kind of exciting all the in
harvesting mode all the
things you're picking up right right no
i mean it's the thing that is
i keep on thinking it's going to be more
difficult than it is now that's a you
know that's a
who knows what um i mean the one thing
so the the the um
the thing that's been a was a big thing
that i think we're pretty close to
i mean i can give you a little bit of
the road map it's sort of interesting to
see
it's like what are particles what are
things like electrons how do they really
work
are you close to get like what what's uh
are you close to trying to understand
like the atom the elect
electrons neutrons protons okay so this
is this is the stack so the first thing
we want to
understand is uh the quantization of
spin
so particles this they kind of spin they
have a certain
angular momentum that angular momentum
even though
the masses of particles are all over the
place you know the electron has a mass
of
0.511 mmv the you know the proton is 938
mev
et cetera et cetera et cetera they're
all kind of random numbers the
the spins of all these particles are
either integers or half integers
and that's a fact that was discovered in
the 1920s i guess
um the uh i think
that we are close to understanding why
spin is quantized
um and that's a and it appears to be a
quite elaborate mathematical story about
homotopic groups in
twister space and all kinds of things
but bottom line is
that seems within reach and that's
that's a big deal because that's a very
core feature of understanding how
particles work in quantum mechanics
another core feature is this difference
between particles that obey the
exclusion principle
and sort of stay apart that leads to the
stability of matter and things like that
and particles that love to get together
and be in the same state
things like photons that um and that's
what leads to
phenomena like lasers um where you can
get sort of coherently everything in the
same state
that difference is the particles of
integer spin
our bosons like to get together in the
same state the particles of half integer
spin of fermions
like electrons that they tend to stay
apart
and so the question is can we can we get
that in our models
you